kommen wir zur nächsten frage und zwar
da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt
ich habe noch nie ein striplokal von
innen gesehen hätte was geht ab und
jetzt willkommen bei einem neuen video
ja heute bin ich leider nicht alleine
ich habe marie dabei und wer wollte ihm
hallo sagen hallo wir haben uns für
heute eine wirklich im alltag challenge
rauskamen ich habe das glaube ich vor
zweieinhalb jahren das erste mal gemacht
haben einem kanal haben wir das nicht
schon mal gemacht irgendwann mit der bis
jetzt noch nicht gemacht und zwar mit
christian vielleicht jemand kurzer
ausschnitt dass ich noch viel jünger aus
oder eigentlich genauso wie jetzt offen
und hell was nochmal klasse challenge
einfach und zwar schön heißt das ich hab
noch nie und zwar kennt ihr das ja
wahrscheinlich alle es geht heute um ich
hab noch nie das spielen einige so die
haben spielen zu wir spielen so wie ich
jetzt erklären werde also folgendes ich
habe zehn fragen heraus gesucht wir
haben ja alle einmal so ein schild mit
diesem kreuz drauf und eins mit ok drauf
und wir sitzen ja in diesem kreis das
heißt immer wenn ich also das heißt
immer wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel wenn
ich sage ich habe noch nie cola
getrunken und duschen cola getrunken
hast müsste ich für dich so zeigen du
müsstest für mehr an ihnen zeigen was
wir dringend werden müsste für mich
zeigen was er denkt und danach wird
aufgelöst
also nicht ja das ist doch nicht
kompliziert also nicht jeder für sich
selber
das ist mein kopf ist gerade wirklich
ich muss für dich zeigen genau wir
machen wir ein erstes beispiel und dann
gucken war ob das der muss sie zu mich
zeigen marie wir fangen jetzt mal ganz
anders ist noch nichts schlimmes oder so
und zwar ich habe noch nie
nur damit es versteht oder halt nicht
ihr habt noch nie über eine woche im
krankenhaus eine einzige frage wenn ich
denke dass er das gemacht hat dann nach
dem haken schwierig ne freiheit ich habe
noch nie länger als eine woche im
krankenhaus verbracht was muss ich denn
jetzt machen du musst jetzt für mich
zeigen ob ich das schon schweizer
unternehmens gemacht hat dann hier
hatten
dann also denkst du ich hab schon
gemacht weil ja ja und ich müsste jetzt
für dich dann zeigen meist und jetzt hab
ich jetzt aber verstanden oder und
merlin du warst noch nie immer eine
woche im krankenhaus ne bis jetzt noch
nie kann was ja ja mancher und du hast
ich habe für die hier ja ich war schon
über eine woche und du auch nicht aber
was jetzt verstanden ja nicht so wie
beim letzten videos und als wir das
letzte mal dass dieses video machte
wurde alex die ganze zeit unsere badisch
betrieb mit euch ist es aber auch
anstrengend manchmal so kommen wir zur
ersten frage also eigentlich im zweiten
ich habe noch nie ein anderes fahrzeug
beschädigt und bin einfach weiter
gefallen also egal wie man es jetzt
beschädigt hat man kann auch gegen
gefallen sein keiner genau einfach
weggefahren
ich muss ja jetzt will ich doch schon
wieder unseren keine ahnung ich weiß ich
ich glaube nicht dass merlin ist schon
machen werden erst sparen nur nicht so
lange und so oft du einen erde welches
ich wünschte irgendwie mit meinem auto
gegen seinen ex verein
ich bin ich so was habe ich dann gemacht
wenn ich hatte einfach so hast du jetzt
im fall gemacht
ja und ich denke von dir also kleine
aufklärung früherer ich weiß nicht ich
war vielleicht so 10 da bin ich immer
city roller gefahren und einmal bin ich
gegen so eine kante gefahren und daneben
stand so ein schönes neues rotes auto
und ich bin mit dem city roller mit dem
lenker richtig gegen das auto irgendwie
gegen die tür davon war da war so eine
richtige welle drin also jetzt nicht zu
krass aber es war schon eine delle und
ich dachte mir verzichten jetzt sehr gut
real und theoretischen punkt aber macht
es ja nur so dass wir möglichst leid
spieler von mir ja so kommen wir zur
nächsten frage ich habe noch nie von
meinen eltern geld geklaut
das macht man ja irgendwie man ja ich
weiss nicht bei uns dass somit haben sie
ein kleines städtchen dastehen aber
immer nur so ein euro stücke 50 cent
also ganz wenig kleingeld und früher
habe ich mir vor dass respekt und zum
abdrehen und das können wir damit haben
wir das ja beantwortet
was war das meiste was mal geklaut ist
das insofern stimmt lohmar 10 10 war
schon mal drin
ich weiß dass ein job schon zehner war
das maximale
aber jammern ist auch nie gemerkt naja
ich glaube mehr wird aufgefüllt generis
an dieser stelle auch von mir kommen wir
zur nächsten frage und zwar da bin ich
jetzt mal gespannt
ich habe noch nie ein striplokal von
innen gesehen und ich war auch schon mit
ja okay bei dir ist es ja eigentlich was
anderes was sollte da
junggesellenabschieden als oder
vereinigen ich kann es eigentlich noch
ganz interessantes zu sehen
eine halterung soll ich ein keiner weiß
was zulässig
also du weißt nicht wo er nicht ich auch
nicht also doch aber schon öfter machen
das kann man jetzt gar nicht mehr zählen
an einer hand
[Musik]
das erste mal mit 16 in ungarn
ich habe noch nie ein autounfall mit
mehr als 200 euro schaden verursacht bei
dir gefährlich so oft auto also nein du
hast noch nicht lange führerschein und
ich schon also so stimmt wobei man auch
sagen was ich bin nun wirklich kein
schlechter autofahrer und das war eine
kleine schramme lässt schon länger her
auf jeden fall müsse eine kleine kleine
schramme dann muss man das ganze teil
abgenommen werden und das hat dann mal
500 euro kostet oder so ist immer
ärgerlich aber einen großen ausland fall
wo jetzt wirklich dann auch mal 34 5000
euro schaden sind hatte ich auch dann
will ich auch nicht eigentlich ist nur
fragen wie man hier der haken
ja das kann ich denn dafür wenn ihr in
eurem auto das waren jetzt die zweite
auto frage ja aber das erste habe ich ja
auch bei dir auch nichts mit dem auto zu
schnell dagegen auf 1 hat diese frage
wird jetzt das ok immer stand
dann können wir jetzt wieder zu einer
allgemeinen fragen ich habe noch nie bei
einem bild eine ausrede benutzt um
wieder gehen zu können hatte irgendwer
von euch überhaupt schon mal irgendwann
haken ist auch schon länger her stimmt
schon über ein jahr her jetzt acht
monate ist das ist ungefährlich
das war also es war schon gemein ich
denke mir das einmal gesagt ich habe
gesagt ich habe irgendwie was sollte es
im getränkedose ich hab gesagt wird was
ins getränk rein gemacht und ich muss
jetzt nach hause mir ging's richtig
schlecht oder
bisher war das dann bei einer party oder
nein nein nein wir waren die jungs
unterwegs date hat jetzt zusammen feiern
ich habe noch nie gesagt ich bin single
obwohl ich in einer beziehung war
ach so also wenn ich selber beziehung
bin dass ich dann gesagt dass ich
ziemlich wird also ich würde zu dir
sagen dass du hast schon mal gemacht
hast nein ein flügel zu dir sagt dass
man sich niemals in sachen das würdest
du niemals x ach so ich würde es
natürlich auch nicht machen
nein aber ich will das aber jetzt mach
ich habe das glaube ich falsch
verstanden
ich habe glaube ich gesagt ich wäre in
der beziehung obwohl ich nicht mehr
damit jung war ja ja und das habe ich
schon total auf gemacht weshalb das
sogar gestanden da war den markt waren
auch die mittlerweise nach aber ich habe
das sogar auch schon mal anders gemacht
das ist schon so lange her dass die
ganze zeit der haken dran kommen wir zur
nächsten frage ich habe noch nie etwas
im internet bestellt weil ich mich nicht
getraut habe es in echt zu haben
du kannst das ja dann gemacht haben also
ich hab es auch noch nicht
[Musik]
dumme frage langweilig kommen wir zur
nächsten frage ich habe noch nie einem
autofahrer einen stinkefinger gezeigt
doch habe ich mich dieser eine davon der
kurve geschnitten hat und weil ich so
sagen habe ich gesehen
also bei mir war es so wir sind früher
fußball gespielt und wir sind immer zu
turnieren gefahren um seinem bulli und
haben so irgendwann kamen wir auf die
idee kommen zeigen wir einfach mal ganz
stimmt anderen autofahrern den
mittelfinger und das haben wir dann auch
immer fleißig gemacht bis irgendwann mal
eine richtig durchgedreht ist und er hat
uns dann ihr wollt uns dann ausbremsen
und wollte uns irgendwie er hat sich das
kennzeichen aufgeschrieben kam auf
irgendwas glaube ich aber das hat sich
dann irgendwann verlaufen weil wir waren
da gerade mal zwölf oder so aber da gibt
es heute schon leute die das dann zu
ernst man kann es ja auch mal stehen
nachhinein aber wenn mir jetzt so ein
achtjähriger in seinem fußball boliden
mittelfinger zeigt und alle sich
kaputtlachen gebe ich jetzt nicht auf
die idee den anzustellen oder soll ich
mich da zu setzen dann klappt dann
bestimmt mir vor ich habe noch nie
jemand anderem ins auto gekürzt
die super g strecke einfach bei mir die
ganze zeit und mehr sagen aber ich hab
mich jemandem mal dabei
das ist aber schon geben
das ist immer eine ausrede ist schon
ewig ja das kann sein aber ja ich hab ja
dann praktisch im auto kurz ich hab
nicht ins auto und kurz aber ich habe im
auto gekürzt richtig eigentlich glaube
ich nicht aber früher haben mal entweder
meine brüder oder ich ins auto costa
wird immer so lange nach bayern gefahren
sind oder machen und ich war besoffen
schon ein dann wird uns immer schlecht
weil so lange autofahrten bei einer
in der mitte sitzen musste er gefällt
ihr eigentlich nicht auch dass du fast
drauf bist ja jetzt wenn du dich hier
hin setzt sieht man das nicht so hier ja
dann würde ich sagen das war jetzt
wirklich ein paar brocken habe fragen
oder das problem war nur dass ihr halt
alle noch nichts davon gemacht habe das
video ist auf jeden fall die daumen nach
oben da schaut bei den beiden gerne auf
instagram koffer ist ja eingeblendet und
wir sehen uns am sonntag wieder
und bis dahin wünsche ich euch ein
eigenes wochenende genießt den freitag
und wir sehen uns sonntag